[Música]
y
hace poco compartió una reunión con
amigos todos hombres de 30 y pico última
de extensión confianza música de fondo
copas de vino alegría
vieron que los hombres ya cuando
alcanzamos cierta edad cierta madurez
desarrollamos una variedad de temas de
conversación
fútbol mujeres fútbol mujeres otros
de repente a quien pregunta que está en
el trabajo y ahí la noche se vino a
pique
insultos lanzados al aire quejas
desmotivación desencanto estrés que no
valora lo que hago
que tengo estrés permanente que quiero
hacer otra cosa
que me siento mal y quiero buscar otro
trabajo y me empecé a preguntar haciendo
un esfuerzo enorme por dejar de pensar
en los grandes temas de la humanidad
fútbol y mujeres porque casi nadie está
contento con su trabajo porque si
alguien dice yo amo mi trabajo será
visto como raro extraño alguien como yo
dónde rhymes la productora guionista de
grey's anatomy scandal que en su charla
te dijo para mí el trabajo es cómo
construir una nación de la nada es
dirigir las tropas pintar un lienzo es
tocar cada nota alta es como correr una
maratón el servicio 11 y es todas esas
cosas al mismo tiempo me encanta
trabajar
qué envidia no que van a sentir todo eso
cuando trabajamos
porque no lo estamos sintiendo
empecé a buscar respuestas y me encontré
con una charla de stel pérez
que habla de la falta de deseo en el
matrimonio y dije claro perdemos la
pasión por el trabajo así como perdemos
la pasión por la persona que alguna vez
amamos sería un desgaste pero lo explica
muy bien dice que el matrimonio era una
institución económica en la que te daban
una pareja para toda la vida en términos
de estatus social chicos compañerismo
pero ahora queremos que nos des todo eso
y además que sea nuestra mejor amiga
confidente apasionada amante y vivimos
el doble de tiempo la menor edad también
familiaridad dame predictibilidad dame
sorpresa y pensamos que está todo dado y
que los juguetes y la lencería nos
salvarán
en los trabajos ocurrió algo parecido
nuestros padres o abuelos entraba en una
empresa y se quedaba en casi toda la
vida y hoy se cambia de trabajo más
rápido de lo que tardas en conocer a tu
próximo match let inder
pasa que uno se desmotiva en el
desencanto no será entonces que tenemos
expectativas muy altas con respecto al
trabajo
pedimos reconocimiento liderazgo
motivación propósito participación
porque no estamos sintiendo todo eso
vieron que los presos se preguntan entre
ellos cuánto tiempo hace que están
cumpliendo su condena y por qué están
allí los empleados se hacen las
preguntas las diferencias o sutiles un
convicto dice estoy adentro hace tres
años y medio
robo a mano armada un empleado dice
estoy en la empresa hace tres años y
medio cuál es a pagar compras y
auditorías
toda metáfora de la realidad
será que entonces
sentimos todo esto este desencanto
y la realidad es que pasamos en el 90%
de nuestras vidas
pero no pasamos un tercio de nuestras
vidas trabajando si consideramos una
semana laboral de 40 horas al año
trabajamos más de 1.900 horas
nuestras horas de vigilia se van
trabajando a medida por lo que
consideramos el trabajo algo tortuoso
tendríamos sentiríamos en nuestros
momentos de lucidez y sufrimiento la
angustia
al parecer es así un estudio de gallup a
nivel mundial informa de casi el 90%
la gente no está contenta con su trabajo
y sentimos de motivación lo vemos como
una frustración desencanto más que algo
desafiante laredo
la pregunta es por qué no estamos
sintiendo así y hay varias respuestas
escucharán alguna vez el principio de
maximizar el valor del accionista
o
de aplicar despidos masivos para que
cierre el balance
arrancar a los empleados según su
performance echando al 10% de los que
están abajo y ascendiendo al 10% están
arriba
es una práctica muy habitual en las
empresas de hoy por hoy esto no quiere
decir que el dinero no sea importante es
importantísimo sencillita para que la
empresa siga funcionando el tema es que
la gente viene antes que el dinero
y las empresas entienden que la gente
viene al dinero efectivamente están
ganando más dinero otra razón por la que
las empresas
por la otra razón por la que estamos
contentos con otro trabajo si la falta
de líderes
en un estudio de la carne que compró
algo que ya sabemos el 75% de las
personas
dejan un trabajo no por el trabajo que
hacen propiamente visto sino por sus
jefes uno no renuncia a una organización
uno renuncia a las personas renuncian a
un jefe en uno mismo un jefe que un
líder escucharon esa frase que dice el
factor común de todas mis relaciones
amorosas fallidas soy yo
hay un link una conexión entre como
tratamos a los empleados y cómo tratamos
a los clientes si los colaboradores que
son la cara y el cuerpo de la empresa
ante los clientes no están motivados
están desencantados están con temor los
clientes pagan las consecuencias te
dejan de elegir y vendes - muy sencillo
de entender sin embargo hay empresas y
empresas grandes multinacionales
valuadas en billones de dólares con
líderes formados en las mejores
universidades del mundo que no están
priorizando el bienestar de su gente y
ocurren cosas como esta el abril de año
pasado
tres momentos previos a un vuelo de
united airlines que salía de chicago
hacia el güisquil los empleados informan
que cuatro pasajeros debían abandonar la
aeronave ya que la agonía ha precisado
sus asientos
como es habitual ofrecieron algo de
dinero
consiguieron tres personas que se
bajaron
las cuestiones que debían bajar una
persona más y nos ofrecieron más dinero
entonces hicieron un sorteo le tocó a de
invitado un médico estadounidense de
origen asiático flaquito desgarbado 69
años el doctor dijo que no iba a bajar
del avión que tenía que ir a trabajar en
a que regresar a su casa entonces los
empleados de united siguieron el
protocolo y llamaron a los agentes de
seguridad locales para que lo invitarán
a bajar
así se ve la escena que dio la vuelta al
mundo
golpes forcejeos gritos sangre en la
cara del doctor que es arrastrado por el
pasillo del avión mientras siga gritando
que quería revisar su casa los pasajeros
también consternados a los gritos
filmando la situación y finalizando la
cena a nivel mundial y para united no
fue ningún chiste perdieron en poco
tiempo un billón de dólares en valor de
mercado destruyeron su reputación y
fueron las más radios del mundo por
varias semanas esto claramente un grave
problema de liderazgo una expresión de
la cultura corporativa del miedo que se
ve en empresas de toda índole empleados
con temor inseguros
deben seguir un protocolo que pueden ser
echados si no lo hacen que tratan a los
clientes de una manera similar a lo que
reciben puertas adentro qué pasaría si
le damos a la gente la confianza y la
autonomía para que tome decisiones si le
permitimos salirse un centímetro del
protocolo
para que hagan lo que tienen que hacer
seguramente con una sonrisa muy grande
hubieran ofrecido 500 son mil dólares
más y alguien será bajado en forma
gustosa sobre todo si el argentino con
la falta que nos hace el ingreso de
divisas
los empleados no son robots no deben ser
ordenados deben ser motivados e
inspirados por eso éxito tanto con el
liderazgo con esos pequeños gestos como
decir buen día obviar la gente los ojos
o preguntarle al colaborador cómo sigue
su mamá que estaba enferma o hablar unos
minutos sobre temas por fuera la laboral
esas pequeñas cosas
constructo en salidas en el tiempo
generan empatía generan conexión crean
que las personas hagan más al menos su
trabajo diario aparecen la confianza y
la cooperación estos pequeños gestos son
fundamentales y la ciencia lo comprueba
son acción preferente la psicología
positiva confirma algo que ya sabemos
y lo comprueba con un pequeño
experimento
tomar un compañero y sonreírle durante
varios segundos intentando que se quede
serio el 80% no puede lograrlo y eso
tiene una explicación
si escanea en mi cerebro se muestra
actividad de que estoy sonriendo
pero si dejó de sonreír y algunos tres
me sonríe
y siguen escaneando mi cerebro se
muestran pequeñas porciones que se
activan llamadas neuronas espejo que
hacen que mi cara forme una sonrisa
liberamos dopamina se eleva mi nivel de
felicidad
el sistema espejo tiene poder sobre el
sistema motor y lo mismo ocurre con los
bostezos vieron cuando vos tenés a uno
utilizamos todos por otro lado en un
aeropuerto sino un grupo de 15
desconocidos e introducen una persona
que empieza a inquietarse a moverse y a
mirarlos continuamente está comprobado
que la mitad de las personas van a hacer
lo mismo entonces no sólo la sonrisa y
el bostezo se contagian sino también la
negatividad el estrés y la ansiedad
lo vemos como el fumador pasivo estamos
como conectados como humanos en forma
inalámbrica por eso la importancia de
mantener actitudes positivas en el
trabajo
y en el resto de los ámbitos el 75 por
ciento del éxito laboral es a causa del
nivel de optimismo manejo social y la
habilidad de ver la presión como un
desafío y no una amenaza si elevamos el
nivel de positivismo de alguien entonces
sentirá lo que llamamos una ventaja de
felicidad el seropositivo funciona mucho
mejor que cuando tan negativo neutro
estresado
se elevan los niveles de inteligencia
creatividad trabajo en equipo rapidez
si mejoran todos los resultados
económicos el sentido positivos 31% más
productivo
trabajamos 37 mejor en ventas los
doctores son 19 por ciento más rápidos
más precisos y más correctos en sus
diagnósticos si nos vamos a ir el
positivismo de alguien entonces
tendremos más éxito ahora porque podemos
trabajar más duro más rápido y con más
inteligencia
tener un trabajo que nos llena de
satisfacción es un derecho no un
privilegio
las empresas y los países tradicionales
hablan de lo tangible los números lo que
se puede ver pero la gente pido a orito
emociones confianza sentimientos lo
intangible lo humano las empresas
modernas que forman líderes positivos al
servicio de la gente están sacando tan
desventajas en esta economía la
reputación en la que vivimos
pero qué pasa si trabajamos en un lugar
que no fomenta este liderazgo positivo
aquí donde cada uno de nosotros puede
hacer un aporte con gestos mínimos pero
consistentes en el tiempo sostenía la
puerta al ascensor incluso si estás
apurado preguntarle un colega como se
hacía entrar un consejo si lo necesita
ayuda a que se le cayeron todo los
papeles al piso
contar a la gente cómo se siente y
realmente interesante por lo que están
contando
y qué pasa conocemos el tiempo lo demás
liberamos oxitocina la hormona del amor
y la felicidad el liderazgo no es el
cargo que figura en tu tarjeta personal
puedes estar en el último escritorio de
la oficina y ser un líder
es una práctica es una elección es una
responsabilidad es la elección de cuidar
a todos los que están a nuestro
alrededor
seamos los líderes que nos gustaría
tener y hagamos nuestros hogares y
nuestras empresas un ambiente más feliz
muchas
[Aplausos]